[Music]
as the coronavirus crisis has unfolded
across the country shelters and rescue
organizations have been pleading with
people to foster or adopt the response
has been fast and furious in fact the
ASPCA says it's experienced a 70 percent
increase in the number of fosters in
both its Los Angeles facilities and here
in New York it's one of the uplifting
stories that we are seeing during these
trying times and a win-win whether
you've got two legs or four good when
the pandemic forced them to work from
home carlie Park and Tom farik decided
the time was right to get a dog you set
out to foster mm-hmm how long did it
take before you knew you wonder adopter
a little funny story
48 hours really I knew almost right away
that I wanted to keep her she just
wanted so much love and I really took to
her
and it wound up working outside we
adopted her the next day
six-year-old Milly has made herself
right at home and her new family
couldn't be happier mm-hmm
it helps provide a little bit of a
routine and a schedule for us and kind
of keep us on track it gives you
something to focus on and gives you a
purpose I feel like in this hard time
she's doing more for me than I am for
her really I really do with much of the
country on lockdown animal shelters and
rescue organizations put the word out to
help empty their kennels the response
has been overwhelming Milly came from a
small New Jersey nonprofit c-spot
rescued which normally gets one to two
requests to foster each month in March
after the state's stay-at-home order it
had more than 50 per day you're getting
even more demand from people who are
stuck at home and perhaps the only
comfort that they can find is from a pet
Mira Horowitz is the founder of lucky
dog Animal Rescue over the last four
weeks it tripled the number of animals
the rescue would see in a normal month
taking in 434 dogs and cats
lucky dog transported them from shelters
across the south to the Washington DC
area
placing 366 of them in foster or
adoptive homes all amid the corona virus
pandemic the animal welfare community is
really struggling with the balance
between saving the animals lives and
saving the people's lives how much
personal interaction is needed to save a
life they're all life or death
transports if we do not take these
animals from the shelter's they are
going to be killed and we don't want
that result particularly when we know so
many people will benefit emotionally
spiritually even physically right like
having a dog makes you go out and go for
a walk in our new normal where Times
Square here is virtually empty I can
tell you that having an animal like my
guy Berkeley really is good for the soul
some of the animal welfare people that I
spoke with said right now it feels like
these guys are the only ones who are
winning but one of their concerns is
what happens to our four-legged friends
a few months from now so there's so much
uncertainty and there's so many unknowns
Matt Berger is president and CEO of the
ASPCA the economic reality of this
healthcare crisis and the economic
crisis are very very real and it's
absolutely concerned about increased
surrenders and abandonment to help the
ASPCA created a five million dollar
rescue and relief fund with two goals
keeping shelter's afloat if donations
dry up and assisting struggling pet
owners with food distribution more
people will need help caring for their
pets and keeping those pets in the home
that's the idea behind providing these
supplies not only to keep that bond in
place in times of crisis when people
rely on their animals for psychological
support but to keep those animals out of
the shelter good job keeping families
together like Carly Tom and Milly
who in a little more than a week formed
what the animal rescue world calls a
forever home I know a lot of people in
the rescue world will say when we go out
to rescue a dog you pick your dog you
save them but the other side of it is
the dog saves you in some way do you
guys feel bad already
I definitely
Carly wakes up everyday and says I don't
know what I would do without this dog
yeah the whole idea of having a purpose
and something to focus your energy on
during this time has been really
wonderful it's so nice to see how much
she loves him she is definitely a
daddy's girl she loves him so much so
it's an awesome and obviously these
rescues are still going on I know people
here that shelters don't have pets there
are still pets out there there are a lot
of transports from the South they're
being very careful in trying to socially
distance when they do them and I think
the most important word Jeff is that if
you are struggling to keep your pet
reach out to some of these organizations
that can help you with food and other
resources someone hopefully will be
there for you Dana I want to
congratulate Berkeley on staying still
30 seconds there during that during your
stand if that was very impressive you
look like a like a step beautiful statue
you know and Dan there was a bit of a
Megan Marco look-alike in your piece I
really enjoyed it thank you